POLICE ARRESTED A 12-YEAR-OLD
FEMALE STUDENT AND RECOVERED A
GUN.
THE CLASSROOM, THE WORKPLACE,
EVEN THE CHURCH HAVE BECOME MUCH
MORE DANGEROUS IN RECENT YEARS.
MORE AND MORE INDIVIDUALS AND
GROUPS ARE TAKING STEPS TO BE
PREPARED FOR A WORST-CASE
SCENARIO SUCH AS A PERSON WITH
THE GUN INTENT ON CAUSING HARM.
BRYAN LLENAS LOOKS AT THE GROWTH
INDUSTRY OF ACTIVE SHOOTER
SITUATION TRAINING.
>> INSIDE THIS BEVERAGE
DISTRIBUTION CENTER, 50
EMPLOYEES ARE ABOUT TO
EXPERIENCE WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE
SEEKING ACTIVE SHOOTER TRAINING
AS THE NUMBER OF SHOOTINGS HAS
INCREASED.
>> I WANT THEM TO BE PREPARED,
KNOW WHAT TO DO, AND WE TRULY
WANT THEM TO GET HOME SAFE.
TRAININGS THEY DO IS UP FROM ONE
OR TWO TO 15.
>> I THINK WE NEED TO GET OUT OF
THE MIND-SET.
IT IS WAY AND IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
>> IN THIS DRILL, THEY USE LIVE
BLANK GUNFIRE AND MOCK PIPE
BOMBS TO MAKE IT AS REAL AS
POSSIBLE.
THE DRILL BEGINS WHEN AN OFFICER
ACTING AS THE SHOOTER WOUNDS A
SALESMAN OUTSIDE.
HE MANAGES TO CALL 911.
POLICE ARE IN ROUTE.
THE DISTRIBUTION CENTER
INITIATES A LOCKDOWN.
THE GUNMAN ENTERS, FIRING
GUNSHOTS AND THROWING PIPE
BOMBS, SHOOTING AN EMPLOYEE.
THE FIRST POLICE RESPONSE
ARRIVES ON SCENE AND THEY GO
TOWARDS THE GUNSHOTS AS THE
SHOOTER FIRES ROUNDS IN THE
>> SHOOT ME!
>> A SECOND POLICE DREAM TREATS
THE WOUNDED AND BEGINS TO
EVACUATE.
EMPLOYEES ARE TAUGHT TO RUN,
HIDE, OR FIGHT.
>> WHEN YOU SEE THE PERSON
RUN.
>> DIDN'T KNOW WHERE HE WAS
GOING, DIDN'T KNOW HOW FAST THE
RESPONSE WAS GOING TO BE.
>> THREE MONTHS AGO JEFF
SESSIONS AWARDED A $5.4 MILLION
GRANT FOR THE ALERT CENTER IN
TEXAS, THE PREEMINENT ACTIVE